m
bonjour à tous je si ces coûts et les
tactiques
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de ce qui
nous préoccupe tous la stabilité des
prix c'est important et c'est pourquoi
nous allons aborder l'inflation alors
c'est quoi l'inflation pour saisir ce
qu'est l'inflation il faut déjà
comprendre l'importance de l'argent
avant nous échanger des objets ou des
services contre d'autres biens ou
services
mais encore fallait-il être d'accord
avec les changes pour faciliter tout ça
ils ont inventé l'argent qui a permis un
échange plus équitable c'est ainsi que
nous avons créé un marché économique
mais l'argent n'a pas toujours conservé
sa mêmes valeurs
il peut être plus ou moins fort cela a
été le cas en allemagne
en 1923 par exemple les prix se sont
tellement envolée qu'il fallait une
brouette entière de billets pour pouvoir
acheter son pain cette dévalorisation de
l'argent et cette baisse du pouvoir
d'achat
c'est cela qu'on appelle l'inflation
mais alors quelles sont les causes de
l'inflation
les causes de l'inflation sont liés à
une mauvaise gestion de l'entrée de
l'argent dans notre économie
s'il y a trop d'argent en circulation
alors il peut avoir de l'inflation
c'est pour cela qu'il faut avoir une
bonne vision du marché économique et qu
s'occupe d'eux morts c'est à la banque
centrale européenne de surveiller tout
ça elle a pour rôle de maintenir la
stabilité des prix et s'efforce de tenir
l'inflation en dessous ou au proche de
2%
ces taux et d'après les économistes est
le plus juste équilibre économique
concrètement comment procès de la banque
centrale européenne pour réguler
l'entrée d'argent dans notre économie
tout comprendre cela il faut saisir
comment fonctionne notre marché
économique
imaginons notre marché économique comme
un immense circuit fonctionnant grâce à
la vigilance de la banque centrale
européenne quand une personne veut
acheter quelque chose une voiture par
exemple
elle va prendre un crédit à la banque
cet argent circule dans notre économie
grâce aux dépenses de cette personne les
entreprises verront donc leur chiffre
d'affaires augmenter ce qui leur
permettra par la suite d'embauché et de
rémunérer les employés par un salaire
mais aussi d'investir pour acheter de
nouvelles machines ou améliorer les
équipements existants et grâce à lui le
il pourra être remboursé à la banque
maintenant imaginons que la banque
accorde à cette personne deux fois plus
de crédit elle voudra acheter deux fois
plus de choses et il y aura donc deux
fois plus d'argent qui circulera dans le
marché économique mais les entreprises
s'adaptent à la demande
il est donc logique que si les gens
beaucoup d'argent alors ils auront les
moyens d'acheter plus cher ainsi les
prix augmentent dans le temps et au fur
et à mesure il faudra beaucoup d'argent
pour acheter quelque chose comme le cas
de l'allemagne en 1923 l'argent perd de
sa valeur
dans cette situation les ménages les
moins aisés seront les plus touchés et
ils auront du mal à acheter de nouveau
avec la forte progression des prix comme
ils n'achètent plus le chiffre
d'affaires des entreprises va être
fragilisés elles auront donc moins
d'argent et ne pourront plus beau chez
nous fournir de salaire et sans cela il
sera difficile pour les ménages de
rembourser leurs crédits
c'est de cette manière que le système
économique s'effondre sur l'inflation
pour contrôler cela la banque centrale
européenne va agir sur les crédits que
les banques foot aux ménages elle va
prêter de l'argent aux banques
en y ajoutant un taux d'intérêt qui sera
directement répercutée sur les crédits
des ménages
ce taux d'intérêt peut-être fort comme
très faible ce qui peut dissuader les
personnes d'emprunter aux banques
lorsqu'il est trop fort c'est de cette
manière que la banque centrale
européenne réguler l'entrée d'argent
dans notre marche économique
j'espère que vous avez bien compris ce
qu'est l'inflation à bientôt pour un
nouvel épisode